brought to you by watchdogs to hack
everything available in consoles
November 15th and on PC November 29 our
gaming accounts contain a lot of
information about us not just what games
we have a water gamerscore is but our
personal and financial details to since
we tie our credit cards to our accounts
to buy games fifa points or loop boxes
these accounts become high-value targets
and people have a tendency of under
estimating just how easy it can be for
black hats to get that information for
example if someone were to crack my
account they'd have got pretty much all
they would need to steal from me my name
date of birth bank account details
potentially even my address this is
enough to steal from me at the very
least but could also be used for
complete identity theft in extreme cases
so this week I thought I'd take a look
at how our gaming accounts get
compromised and what we can do to
protect ourselves online oh yeah and
this episode's brought to you by
watchdogs to a game about hacking and
stealing people's personal information
the irony of that is not lost on me
it's common sense not to give your login
info to strangers on the internet but
there are various ways that you can be
tricked into doing so without even
realizing it I asked cyber security
expert Danny Palmer senior reporter at
leading business technology website
ZDNet to tell me exactly how this can
happen hacking isn't necessarily so
sitting there breaking code now in a
darkened room wearing a hoodie you know
with a no Guy Fawkes mask on taking down
society it can just be a case of ya
stealing email stealing a password and
doing it that way you know socially
engineering someone to give up their
details to gain access to their accounts
like any other account you have like
your facebook account on your email
account your Twitter account if people
can get access to this they will but we
all get emails from PlayStation Network
when you purchase something or go to
support saying it what can we know
here's your purchase what hackers can do
is they can spoof where that email is
coming from they can say that you'll
come up in your email header saying this
is the PlayStation Network email address
and it will come up with some
information saying usually with
something in it saying click here to
denote do this ah yes the old phishing
scam ah these have been around for about
20 years now and they're a relatively
easy way to obtain someone's login
details general rule of thumb here is if
an official email looks fake it probably
is there's multiple things that give
phishing scams away spelling errors in
the coffee impersonal introductions and
demanding personal information are all
telltale signs if you hover over any
links and the URL doesn't seem to match
what it ought to then steer clear
likewise websites promising to level you
up in a game get you specificity vents
or massively bump up your gamerscore are
also a really easy way for someone to
get access to your account take the poor
case of eleven-year-old destiny player
coo coo night HD a user going by Kermit
the Frog joined him in a share play
session on PlayStation 4 taking control
of his game with the promise of boosting
his level 31 warlock and level 26 Titan
with an exploit he'd found in the game
well it turns out that Kermit the Frog
was lying and instead of helping out
cuckoo night he deleted his near max
level characters right in front of him a
hard lesson for cuckoo night HD to learn
but an important one seriously be
careful about who you trust with your
details don't give access to your
accounts to strangers and most
importantly if you want max level
characters put in the work yourself
you'll learn how the net can entertain
you and take you the far off locations
and meet new people and at the end of
the tape I'll be back to tell you how to
safeguard your computer so that you can
reduce your concerns about the kinds of
websites your children can visit you
never can be too careful now when I was
a kid and going on the internet for the
first time it was such a big thing to
keep your identity and your personal
information vague obviously with the
onset of social media that's fallen by
the wayside somewhat but still be
careful about what you post online a
process called social engineering is a
time-consuming but effective way that
so-called hackers can manipulate you
into revealing personal information
about yourself disguised as idle
chitchat they tease personal information
that can then be used to impersonate you
from their forwards just can contact
customer services for Xbox Live or
playstation network and poses you in
order to get a password reset email
sometimes they have to go through
multiple customer service agents
guessing answers as they go but once
they crack it say goodbye to your
account user hockey's underscore dilemma
on reddit posted a harrowing account on
our / gaming last year of just how his
playstation network account was targeted
and taken over by someone who did just
that so how can we protect ourselves
from people trying to hijack our
accounts make sure you have a secure
password on all of your accounts of your
gaming accounts your email accounts your
social media accounts you don't want
have a password like 123456 something
that's easily crackable what you want to
do is you want to have a strong password
involving
letters numbers capital letters
something that's not gonna be easy to
easy to crack because the stronger that
is the less likely people are to get in
and you also don't want to use the same
password across multiple accounts for
example if someone managed to say they
managed to breach your email address for
example and you use the same password
for your email address and as you do for
your xbox live account if you use the
same login and password for that they
can get in there so it's it can be
tricky to manage all these passwords but
it's the best way to stay safe and
another way to protect yourself against
would be hackers is to enable two-factor
authentication on your accounts with two
factor authentication you are safer
essentially it means even if someone has
your email address and password or your
login details they'll need another
device to be able to get in they need to
actually say for example if some tried
to break into a playstation network
account and you had that tied up a
two-factor authentication tied up to
your mobile phone to get a text message
when there's an unauthorized login they
need to actually have no your phone and
be in person with them in order to get
that code to login so it does make
account safer but as with all of these
things it's nothing can be a hundred
percent bulletproof so there we are some
tips about keeping your gaming account
safe online for more videos like this
one make sure to LIKE and subscribe to
gamespot and for more of me find me on
Twitter at Lucy James games I'll see you
next time